I think you know to just to touch up on
the point I was making when you talk
about racism and privilege it's
impossible to quantify they can say
something like white people are stopped
this many times and black people are
stopped by police this many times and
that doesn't prove or mean anything yeah
you'll hear from the left they say
that's proof of racism and then you'll
hear from you know the right that's
proof they're committing more crimes
right so it is interesting because
simply by nature of getting arrested
does not mean that you know black people
are committing more crimes however it
also doesn't mean that cops are being
more racist it's what's the
determination so the left chooses what
they want to believe cites the data and
claims the data is true based on their
personal argument about it and I think
that happens a lot with data I think
data can be used to be proved to prove
whatever it is that you want it to tell
you
um John mcquarter talks about this he
talks about how the uh you know
difference in percentage is very similar
to the difference in percentage of
poverty the difference in percentage of
crimes committed is different is very
similar to it's like like the same
percentage I think he said it was 2.5
percent
um and he's a you know he's a
fascinating thinker as well but I think
that that's a big part of the problem is
people just use the data to construct a
narrative that they then support with
everything else that they're doing
decide that those are facts and then
perpetrate them I see that a lot in the
climate science arguments when it's like
saying there are six sandwiches and you
eat one sandwich a day in six days we're
not gonna have any sandwiches everybody
in six days we're out but they take no
account of outside influences that
someone might bring a delivery of
sandwiches that we can figure out how to
reuse the sandwich well you had John
Kerry recently saying that we had nine
years left until the end of the world
you said something like that and he was
parroting what AOC had said a few years
back when she said there were 12 years
left and a reporter asked Jen saki the
White House Press Secretary if there
were nine years left and she said
something like I don't have anything
else to preview for you on that and it's
like
do you really think there's nine years
left until it's the end of the world I
and that is what alarmism is right like
we used to use whale oil for everything
um we used whale oil in lamps and to
make you know was it Tallow candles yeah
like well that's Moby Dick right Moby
Dick was it was a was a book about
energy consumption and like harvesting
energy
so we hunted whales to near Extinction
that was a big problem until we found a
new energy source and then we could you
know congratulate ourselves for saving
the whales we would not have saved the
whales if we didn't find some better
energy source people don't understand
this too I was reading about slavery
slavery didn't end because of some moral
imperative from good people right it
ended because of invention the cotton
gin yeah yeah and they're like there
were good people trying to end slavery I
mean the Abolitionist Movement was a
I think an important moral perspective a
lot of really amazing people and one of
the bloodiest Wars ever fought to end
slavery but the Catalyst was for a lot
of people
they're unwilling to give up their
comfort
so they were it wasn't until people got
access to cheaper goods and no longer
needed it that they were all of a sudden
having this moral Epiphany about why it
was so wrong to do right the Romans
never ended slavery yeah well so we
saved the whales just like you mentioned
it was only once we didn't need them we
were all of a sudden like oh hey you
know you gotta save the whales now so
then the question becomes are these
sustainable energy resources that were
plunking so much money into and
demanding that we remake our society in
service to are they really energy
efficient enough to do what needs to be
done to you know further Humanity's
interests are they wind and solar not
alone not alone and we're shutting down
nuclear energy plants right that's
that's not smart and I don't think that
is super smart I think that's sort of
Dumb and we're shutting down nuclear
energy plants because why because the
Baby Boomers it made them feel icky
do you know about the uh the manure the
projected manure crisis of New York no
so I guess at the turn of the century
1800s to 1900s there were just
scientists and individuals warning that
due to population growth that the cities
would have you know six foot piles of
horse crap everywhere in every corner
because people needed horses horses take
dumps and when you're going through the
city and the city's growing there's
going to be too many horses so they were
generally concerned about it
then the car was invented
and then it was okay and then all of a
sudden right so so
I suppose the issue is
you know I I think it's fair to say we
we have to keep close a close eye on
what we do as humans because to think
that we're Invincible or Immortal I
believe would be stupid but also we
should be heavily focused on advancing
technology I agree not shutting it down
and so unfortunately for us it's a key
component of the left to oppose nuclear
energy like even Tulsi gabbard I'm a big
fan she opposed nuclear energy and I was
like I think I think you could convince
her if you actually show her the data
modern nuclear technology nuclear modern
nuclear technology is fantastic it's
carbon neutral it's massive energy
return on energy invested and it's
something we should be doing right and I
think we don't and we completely
discount the waste that is inherent in
sustainable energy those wind turbines
they die they can't be reused you know
they're going to litter the landscape
the kinds of materials that are used to
create solar panels you know what's in
those things how are they constructed I
don't think that I don't think we're
actually considering
um you know the side effects of any of
those things we're just assuming that
because it's sun and wind and those are
friendly and filled with flowers it's
all okay have you seen the original Iron
Man
no I gotta squeeze in my pop culture go
for it so the original Iron Man they
have a you know Stark comes back from
the desert you know he built this thing
called an arc reactor he's with obadai
stain who's the spoiler alert it's been
you know what 13 years he's the villain
and they're looking at the Arc Reactor
it's like just gigantic you know glass
cylinder thing and
Tony says to him he's like look we you
know we should look into Arc technology
and oh but I says we built that for the
hippies the thing was never cost
effective that's that's how I feel with
a lot of the investment into photo
voltaic solar and a lot of wind wind can
be great
but you can't use it alone you what
happens when the wind is is weak what
happens when you don't have battery
power so it's a good it's a good
supplemental but there has to be a
stronger and robust backup system one of
the problems with photovolta voltaic
this is solar panels right because
there's also other kinds of solar energy
that can be generated so like mirrors
reflecting into big Vats of like salt
water or something well there's the
passive solar versus the PVS yeah so one
of the people one of the things people
don't realize about photovoltaic solar
is it's a luxury atom for wealthy people
well it sure is I learned this when I
actually talked to a Solar Company and I
was like it's gonna be great it's going
to save me money right and they're like
no they're like maybe in 20 or 30 years
they're like but the reality is people
get these because it's a backup system
and I was like what and I was like I
thought we were getting this because
it's going to reduce our energy
consumption and they're like I mean a
little bit but the amount of carbon and
energy put that is used to build these
things you're not going to get that back
for a couple decades so hopefully
you know we're getting better and better
energy output from our photo photo full
photo voltaic you can still say PVS PVS
there we go PV technology
um it's getting better and better and
maybe we'll get to that point where it
does become immediately more cost
effective but people need to understand
the machines to [ __ ] transport wind
turbines
burning carbon and you need lots of big
trucks to move these massive things we
don't have enough superconductors too to
get this energy where it needs to go we
don't have enough you know energy
storage so even when you have PVS on
your roof and everything like that
you're still sending the energy back to
the Grid it's not off grid it's just
you're generating you're like your own
little power plant generating energy and
sending it back we ended up not doing
solar I was kind of bummed and the main
reason was they were like yeah you'll
have a it's like a generator and I was
like so if I just do like a diesel
generator it's better faster cheaper and
I'll waste less energy because you fill
up your diesel tank one time and you
never use it that's right and then it
just sits there for you yep and so they
were like
yeah but you know maybe after 20 years
and I was like but won't there be wear
and tear for 20 years won't I have to
deal with like getting the roof fixed
taking these things down they're like
yeah yeah and I was like okay well you
don't want to put PVS on a roof that's
going to need repair exactly and so you
know uh I they do this new thing with
Tesla they're called solar shingles and
it's
when I actually talk to them about it
the the function of a roof the repairs
needed it just didn't make sense I mean
there's a lot of little technology the
question is should we
base our entire Society on it should we
spend all of this money to re-educate
everyone so that this is the only thing
they know how to do
I I don't think that's a great idea not
necessarily no the problem is like you
you look at these marxists they talk
about Marx and his writings about the
future and where Humanity ends up and um
and they love to cite Star Trek and
that's very offensive to me as a huge
Star Trek why is it offensive they claim
the Federation and Star Trek is
communist oh I don't think it is it's
not communist people have beachfront
property there's Federation credits
there's there's hierarchy but you can
choose to serve or not it's classically
liberal it's it's a very classically
liberal society and you can still have
your own Vineyard it's exactly and
they've created and and they have uh
they they've ended scarcity through
replication that's what changed their
system but I digress that's just a story
but these Communists like to claim
that's the future that Marx envisioned
the Communist future and I'm like sure
maybe but Marx didn't unders like you
what you guys are proposing won't exist
until we invent replicators things that
can literally pull Ambient Energy from
the air and convert energy into matter
maybe once we have that yeah
right and so all of these people who are
talking about the future green energy
I'm like maybe we're just not there
maybe we should be putting all this
money into Fusion technology well or
maybe we should be you know allowing a
little bit more of the market to decide
how things go instead of using moral
cudgels to destroy some kinds of energy
generation and to bolster other kinds it
doesn't seem like
um
I just don't think the federal
government should be involved in
determining how we're all going to be
living and working if you look at it
that way it just doesn't make any sense
well I'll give you the um I guess
predictable Centrist position I don't
think the free market can can solve the
issue for the most part like a like a
totally laissez-faire just open go you
know go for it because I think we'd end
up like yeast in a bottle just farting
ourselves to death you know what works
in the short term is and eventually we
hit a wall and then there may be a point
where we go off a cliff however a
command economy absolutely doesn't work
some random bureaucrat deciding we're
going to build this thing makes
literally no sense well and it's Joe
Biden and his his cronies deciding that
we're going to do it this way and you
don't see data as to why it should be
done that way all you hear is that this
is compassionate somehow it's
compassionate to the Earth or it's
emotional manipulation yeah and I don't
think that the um using compassionate as
a compassion as a as they're just
beating us to death with our own
compassion and that's true with the the
race stuff and the gender stuff as well
don't you feel bad for everybody well
sure I feel bad for everybody okay well
then you have to do all of these things
to ameliorate create yourself feeling
bad for everybody and that's when used
that's when you see the Liberals start
to fall asleep they figure I've done the
right thing now I get to live how I
please you know everyone else is going
to live how they out they please and
they're not realizing that remaking
Society in this way is just going to
destroy it but it works on conservatives
too
once enough people fall for the
emotional argument the hard-line
conservatives fall in line because they
have no choice well they don't know what
else to do and they're not really being
supported I mean we're looking also at a
I think a um
sort of schism in conservatism now right
so you had the bow tie wearing we were
talking about before the bow tie wearing
uh socially liberal physically
conservative types
um who just wanted to sit back and get
their tax breaks and not really worry
too much about anything else and let the
rest kind of just roll along and they
did that and this is the society that we
have and now you have a new group of
conservatives
um and I think you're seeing it in a lot
of independent conservative media as
well and they're say they're much more
socially conservative they're more
fiscally liberal but not with regard to
the same causes that the Liberals are
pushing and I think there's going to be
a split like if we do see 2022 if we do
see conservatives taking the house back
uh I think we're going to see
the new conservatives doing it we're not
going to see these old style Lindsey
Graham you know Mitch McConnell type of
guys doing it milk toast Mitch that's
what I'm calling we're not yeah I mean
we're not gonna see those that that
style of conservatism is not coming back
and I don't think it should I think it
was
sort of arrogant and boring and uh
didn't really take into consideration
what it turns out half the population is
interested in I just realized Mitch
McConnell actually reminds me of the
original milk toast character Casper
milk toast really yeah so that's you
you're familiar with work I I was not
I'm just always impressed that I can
spell it it's an old comic about a guy
who is like deferential and weak and
milk toast because the artist considered
that to be just like the most boring
breakfast you could have military and so
it's just like he's just an old man with
glasses he has a mustache you know
McConnell doesn't but I look at
McConnell you know we like to joke I'm
the milk toast fence sitter Tim
paulocentris whatever but the reality is
I get heated on this week you know on
the show talking about say 2A or taxes
or billionaires manipulating elections
but Mitch McConnell what is he doing
what does he ever really do yeah I mean
he's trying to push back on this
critical race Theory thing but I don't
only only after they lose everything now
yeah I don't think he's gonna win he was
also
um pushing back against Trump I think
rather substantially and Lindsey Graham
only came around after it turned out his
constituents wanted him to support Trump
and Lindsay will walk up and high five
Kamala Harris well he'll do whatever he
has to do to stay in office I think
that's pretty clear thanks for checking
out this flip from the timcast IRL
podcast if you want to see the full show
come back to this channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time